[Música]
que ser yo sé mi automóvil no estés la
pero llegó primero que yo
de ser una broma tienes que reír muy
bien
les han dado datos muy interesantes les
han dicho cosas muy muy padres pero
vamos a olvidar esa seriedad
aunque vamos a empezar con una pregunta
muy muy seria y se las hago a todos
la última vez que fueron a un centro
comercial
la última vez que salieron por la noche
cuántas sillas de ruedas observaron
cuántas personas
con muletas llegaron a ver cuántas
personas invidentes
se encontraban en todos los lugares con
las mencionó
y llevaron a segundos para que lo
piensen si los segundos
seguramente ya tienen su respuesta ahí
o ninguna persona
muy pocas y me refiero muy pocas que nos
pueden contar con los dedos de sus manos
bueno ya les dijeron cosas muy bonitas
de mi que me amo raúl y demás soy
psicólogo soy soy conferencista de
profesión
una aventura era por decisión propia y
un scout de corazón real scouts
y como ya también mencionaron tengo un
proyecto llamado ruedas mando caderas
que consiste ruedas mando cadenas y
cierras mi mochila
y viajar por méxico mucho y le arterial
mente no pedir right aventón y demás
cuando méxico
y ese reto que me propuse no fue
suficiente para mí de si quitarle la
ayuda económica entonces se volvió mi
silla de ruedas
mi mochila y ningún peso
empecé mutilando por mexico me encantó
me pareció increíble conocí a muchísimas
personas y cuando ese reto aún no fue
suficiente
y méxico me quedo pequeño que no es nada
pequeño contiene en sudamérica cuando
estando en sudamerica tengo que admitir
los
todo esto lo escondí en mi casa no le
dice que está con un primo o algo así y
cada vez que le llaman a mi primo
seguramente les dice que está en el baño
y no sé cómo jamás sospecharon que dura
mucho tiempo en el baño
podrían estando estamos sudamérica
alguien no invitó a escribir un blog y
empecé a escribir un blog y esto se
empezó a ver un poco más viral madrigal
y un momento en el que fue imposible
esconder el secreto no el secreto estará
mochi le ando por el mundo ya estaba en
algunas partes y me saludaba gente y me
dice que es que leía mi blog y el pri el
primer gran proyecto documentado
que hice fue de la puerta de mi casa de
su casa hasta tocar alaska encierros sin
ningún peso
igual no viendo right con la nom en
camiones porque esa es otra no le digan
por favor a las autoridades soy un
experto en en colarme en lugares
espero necesidad o aquí sin pagar
y ya no pues fue ese primer gran reto
documentado
pero la verdad es que real más no
cadenas no trata de estas locuras de una
mochila nada de dinero y todas esas
cosas raras las no cadenas tiene tiene
un trasfondo
y normalmente termino las pláticas con
una historia que alguna vez estando con
amigos en un bar
y a contarla y un gran amigo paco que es
el chico que me ayuda mucho en estas
pláticas para mejorarla siempre me dijo
tienes que cerrar siempre con esa
historia esa historia explica todo lo
que haces para mí es una historia planta
no se lo va a platicar
no crean que ya terminé
se la va a platicar porque quiero que
éste sea algo así como un after show lo
que sigue después d
entonces
es notorio que tengo una discapacidad
tengo distrofia muscular dulce es una
enfermedad degenerativa avanzando con el
tiempo
y que en una sierras a los 14 años
ya estando en una silla de ruedas alumna
de mi abuelo con una bicicleta a la casa
y me dijo
raúl todo enseñar a andar en bicicleta
y yo inmediatamente pensé en ser yo
vuelo en bicicleta un chico en una silla
de ruedas
ok vamos a darte chanzas y no tenía
rueditas no tenía nada lo ponía difícil
entonces
tengo que admitirlo mi mayor temor y
estoy seguro que por eso es que me
acuerdo de esta historia
es que fuera que fuera meter un trancazo
digamos los hijos
lo intentamos
y sucedió
me caí y me metí un músico entra en casa
y insistí en volverlo intentar y lo
volvimos a intentar y lo volvemos a
intentar y no volvió a caer y no volvió
a caer y volvió a golpear y movilidad
golpear una tras otra vez pues bueno mi
abuelo y enojado muy enojado créanme me
insistía en que lo volviera a intentar y
lo volvió a intentar una tras otra vez y
yo lloraba ya un adolescente llorando no
son porque les dije eso
el insistía y se enojó quisiera que lo
lograra
y lo sigo intentando y de esa historia
ya pasaron más de 10 años y esa
bicicleta aún está en la parte de atrás
de mi casa ya no sirve esa bicicleta
bicicleta
y esta no es una historia bonita
es una historia que el estanco emocional
pero sigo sin poder andar en bicicleta
y yo sé que esperaba que tal vez les
dijera y lo logré cuando no lo logré y
todavía me da miedo caerme
pero
esa es y esa bicicleta y ese abuelo con
esa idea tan loca que una persona una
silla de ruedas puedan dar en una
bicicleta fue lo que me enseñó y me hizo
darme cuenta que nada era imposible
o por lo menos así lo debemos de creer
sigo pensando que es imposible que una
persona la silla de ruedas para andar
una bicicleta pero bueno
fue esa vez que él me mostró a su modo
sin palabras y con mucho enojo y muchos
golpes
qué
por más imposible que algo pareciera no
perdían nada si lo intentaba
aún así por una caída
entonces chicos tengo que admitirlo
tengo que admitir él es algo y no solo
puede encontrar a nadie por favor
estas pláticas y cuando yo viaje como
les dijeron estuve un año cuatro meses
en áfrica igual silla de ruedas mi
mochila ningún peso cero conocimiento
del árabe muy mal inglés
pero lo pasé increíble y demasiadas
experiencias conocí a más ya dos
personas conocí muchísimos lugares
pero yo no intente
hacer estos viajes porque quisiera dar
pláticas o inspirar de hecho no busco
inspirar si se inspiraron muy mal muy
mal
que busco con esto y se los admito de
corazón
tengo un sueño y sueño como alguna vez
dijo martin luther king
que a todas las personas que tengo
enfrente por lo menos de cada diez
hubiera una persona silla de ruedas
hubiera una persona con un bastón o una
persona invidente que la siguiente vez
que me vaya de antro con mis amigos
ustedes también manden ante rubén feroz
también vean demasiadas personas
discapacitadas no creo que sea la única
persona discapacitada en el mundo y como
llegué les voy a admitir como llegué a
este pensamiento alguna vez estando en
madrid conocí una chica y me decía te
has puesto a pensar que en madrid no hay
muchas personas invidentes
y sí es cierto que muchas personas
invidentes porque será y me lo pregunto
tanto yo
pensé y dije cuestiones genéticas la
comida son españoles tal vez los
españoles no son tan invidentes
y leí mi respuesta y muy agradable ella
me contestó no es cierto así y me dijo
en madrid hay demasiadas personas
invidentes el problema es que no la ves
en la calle porque están en sus casas y
les digo lo mismo ustedes no es que sea
el único chico loco que va a un antro
por los sábados que va al cine que tiene
una pareja el problema es que hay
demasiadas personas con discapacidad
pero no salen de su casa
no sé si por sus miedos de ellos no sé
si por los miedos que les imponen y
existen mil nidos como les dije que era
una sierras a los 14 años
y les admito cuando que en esa silla de
ruedas mi mundo se vino abajo totalmente
no sabía que iba a seguir para mí
no sabía que iba a pasar
y no había nadie que me explicará
que seguía no cuál era el siguiente
capítulo después de caer a una silla de
ruedas
nadie me lo podía decir
para mi suerte
tuve unos increíbles amigos
que me invitan a jugar fútbol sigo
considerando que es trampa que una silla
de ruedas de un portero
y
tuve unos excelentes abuelos y un
excelente familia que estoy seguro que
ellos tenían muchos más temores que yo
estoy seguro que ellos tenían muchas más
dudas
pero nunca me lo hicieron presente y
nunca me lo hicieron saber
chicos les platicaba un poco de esto no
hay y no no me gusta mucho ser visuales
no vamos a usar muchas presentaciones
pero me insistían que tenía que
contarles una historia y que tenía que
contarles esta historia
en la historia
estando en áfrica
aunque ustedes no lo crean me robaron mi
silla de ruedas si no sé quién quiere
robarse la silla raza amarilla
y mochila para una persona sencilla ras
es muy difícil entonces tomar mi silla
de ruedas no no no tomada mi mochila da
dos pasos me sentaba volver a los pasos
arrastrarme mochila y me sentaba y ese
chico se acercó a mí
y me preguntó que qué pasaba que que
tenía que si me podía ayudar en algo y
demás y le platiqué que yo mochila va mi
historia no resultó que él también
mochila va y era de ammán jordania amman
jordania fue mi primer punto en áfrica
ellos qué suerte pues el chico me ofrece
un trato que rechace demasiado veces y
él sigue existiendo
y me dijo te a un trato yo te cargo en
mi espalda si tú me dejas acompañarte en
tus viajes en estos tips de mochilero y
decía me veo ligero pero no estoy tan
ligero no es tan fácil como crees
insistió e insistió con chicos
imagínense la amistad que creas con un
hombre que te carga semanas en su
espalda
qué ves paisajes increíbles
que te ayuda a hablar un idioma que no
tienes ni idea
es la historia que me dijeron tienes que
contarla el rock como el robo de una
silla de ruedas
y me llegó a crear una amistad que estoy
seguro que va a durar para toda mi vida
pues bueno chicos ya le mencioné
rondando cadenas no es eso no es viajar
estoy totalmente seguro y lo repito y lo
repito una tras otra vez tiene una gran
diferencia entre ser una persona con la
discapacidad y sea un discapacitado yo
me considero una persona con la
discapacidad
y la palabra es muy parecida pero es un
mundo totalmente diferente algún día en
un centro local conocí a un chico que
fue el que inició todo esto carlos un
centro local de personas con
discapacidad no un sábado y el otro
sábado lo vi me agregó a mi facebook y
yo pensé que me iba a decir que pedo
como tienes una foto en la pirámide de
giza o que haces en españa o algo así no
y lo primero que me dice es disculpen la
palabra
no que sale de fiesta
y yo
y cómo le haces me subo a mi carro le
doy voy por mis amigos no que
manejas
yo sí pues bueno ya a repetir tres veces
normalmente
la cuarta vez no
y seguían sus no quinta vez uno
tras otro tras otro tras otro y jamás me
pregunto qué como dice páramo chile ar
que como viaje allá que como me fui a su
pregunta es como lo que para mí era
normal como lo hacía y ese chico cada
vez que ves y una pregunta era un
pinchazo a mi burbuja de mentiras que me
burbuja de mentiras sobre mi
discapacidad
porque lo que yo creía como persona
discapacitada todo era una mentira yo
pensaba que yo como persona
discapacitada podía tener una pareja
puede estudiar podía salir de fiesta
poder ir al cine y no
para la mayoría de las personas con
discapacidad eso es un sueño es algo
totalmente inaudito destrata romano
quedan las chicos
quiero contarles una aventura más antes
de despedirme pero quiero que quede
claro eso sus ruedas no quedan a ruanda
no que nos trate de mochila y ramas no
queden a nuestra tierra o ríos
cualquiera usted puede ser parte de
rondando cadenas estoy seguro que sea de
la religión que sean habla en el idioma
que hablen y del color que tengan
todos tenemos algo en común y es que
queremos ser felices todos buscamos la
felicidad yo la busco cada día
para terminar quiero mostrar las fotos
de la aventura más increíble que tenía
y seguramente no es mi aventura más
increíble seguramente la aventura más
increíble seis personas haber creído en
mí
haber tenido mil dudas de cómo una
persona nacida de ruedas y a poder darle
la vuelta al mundo para estudiar aquí
chicos platicando le es como creo en
todo eso como tengo ese sueño de ver las
personas con discapacidad
como tengo ese sueño de que más padres
crean personas con discapacidades
no queda más que despedirme diciéndoles
que siendo estas son mis ruedas
pero yo sí que sólo fueran eso no fueron
las cadenas y no me tuvieran en mi casa
chicos esto fue rondando cadenas soy
raúl rivas un gusto eres todo con
ustedes gracias
[Aplausos]